on l'a appris ce matin des cours
d'information sexuels seront dispensés
dans les établissements dès la prochaine
rentrée scolaire
nous sommes en 1973 une date importante
puisque à partir de 73 les garçons ne
naisse plus dans les choux et les filles
dans les roses il s'agira d'un
enseignement progressif à partir de la
sixième
partant de la reproduction chez les
végétaux et les animaux pour passer à la
reproduction chez les humains c'est le
fruit d'une longue gestation commencé
dans les années quarante puis abandonnée
et ressuscité dans les années 60
pourquoi à cause de ce genre de
témoignage une jeune fille tombée
enceinte à la sortie de son collège
religieux
vous allez rigoler je n'aime absolument
pas ça on n'en parlait pas et au collège
sur mes pages et et j'ai toujours été
dans des pensions religieuse et
religieuse d'abord déjà mais jamais ces
sujets là ce nom pas et alors quant à ma
mère non plus c'était le grand silence
certes c'est la libération sexuelle mais
l'éducation sexuelle ne sut pas de
nombreux parents ne savent pas parler à
leurs enfants comme en témoigne ce
reportage en 69
on est ici dans le premier centre
d'information sexuelle en france ah au
fait
une autre question madame est ce que
vous avez déjà eu des discussions
d'ordre d'éducation sexuelle avec votre
fille
jamais voyez vous madame je ne pense pas
que ce soit une excellente sélection
qu'elles apprennent tout comme ça un peu
à la sauvette les débats télévisés sont
de plus en plus nombreux il ya ceux qui
sont pour
pourquoi arrêter des stylistes naturel à
la ceinture on parle de l'estomac on
parle de toutes sortes de fonctions
physiologiques puis mon du sexe on
s'arrête et ceux qui sont contre
il est déjà le comportement sexuel de
celui qui va faire le court courrier par
commande lui confier vos enfants il
s'agit là peut-être de savoir qui est
cette personne ce monsieur cette date
malgré les oppositions l'information
sexuelle va faire son entrée à l'école
mais attention elle ne concerne que la
procréation la contraception les mst les
relations hommes-femmes
pas de ça dans la classe écoutez le
recteur de paris henri gautier en 73
tous les éléments de langage sont
présents il agit en effet de cours
d'information sexuelle c'est à dire le
cours scientifiques
encore une fois il s'agit de programmes
scientifiques les cours scientifiques
d'information sexuels seront intégrés
dans les programmes scientifiques alors
le jour de la rentrée on interroge et
l'enseignante
toutes les précautions ont été prises il
y à une brochure qui va être donnée à
tous les parents de 6e et 5e des parents
très satisfaits et certains qui trouve
même que cela ne va pas assez loin
moi je trouve que cette information
sexuelle est nécessaire elle est
indispensable mais je pense qu'elle
serait même a commencé aux primaires
elle sera entendue près de trente ans
plus tard en 2001 l'éducation sexuelle
fait officiellement son entrée en
primaire quant à cette distinction entre
information et éducation sexuelle
elle disparaîtra progressivement
[Musique]